[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta edición de enlace
desde República Dominicana Soy Jorge
Hurtado y Hoy estaremos hablando sobre
el flujo migratorio en la frontera
dominicana haitiana con las bandas
criminales tomando cada vez más el
control de Puerto Príncipe de la capital
haitiana ha llevado a un aumento de la
migración en la frontera común entre
estos países eso ha hecho que Santo
Domingo endurezca su política migratoria
inclusive construyendo un muro a lo
largo de la frontera común
en dajabón la ciudad fronteriza del
noreste de dominicana miles de haitianos
cruzan para comprar en el Mercado
binacional o intentar trabajar en ese
territorio entre momentos de Caos el
maratónico proceso migratorio avanza
hasta caer la tarde
mil millones de gente entre todos los
días
juanamente
bonaevo tapa de piano y Puerto Príncipe
también a caer de todos los lugares en
Haití pero organismos de Derechos
Humanos en ambos países denuncian un
incremento significativo de las
deportaciones como parte del
endurecimiento de las políticas
migratorias que emprendes Santo Domingo
por la crisis social y política en su
vecino Haití yo no tengo problema con
nadie pero yo yo en lo personal yo tiene
respeto
si tú no tienes cero la tú no
puedes cruzar pero ahí
igual ya está está muy caliente Pero si
tú puedes si tú quieres ya trabaja Pero
tú cruza más fácil entre las medidas
para controlar la migración se contempla
la construcción de un muro fronterizo
que comenzó hace un año y que dividirá
la isla que comparten ambos países el
muro ya genera opiniones encontradas en
Estados Unidos siquiera ha podido
controlar un muro que ellos tienen la
inmigración aquí quizás se pueda mejorar
se pueda controlar un poco pero un poco
difícil porque algunas veces los mismos
militares son los que cogen el dinero
para dejarlo pasar entonces no es
posible que un haitiano sea ileganda
jabón que no se va a ir que viene a
trabajar aquí a dajabón Más sin embargo
lo que están en Santiago en lo que están
en otra en otra provincia no son
ilegales no tienen papeles
a veces no pasa nada pero hace una cosa
que estás haciendo desde otro país
nosotros no tiene que ver con eso puedes
hacer lo que tiene que hacer pes el muro
no cubrirá los 390 kilómetros de la
frontera común y se construirá en las
áreas más pobladas y sensibles de las
cinco provincias fronterizas montecristi
dajabón Elías piña Independencia y
pedernales contará con 19 Torres de
vigilancia y 10 puertas de acceso una
controversial medida que el gobierno de
Luis abinader impulsa para garantizar la
seguridad en su territorio
están cruzando la frontera en grandes
cantidades
Esa es la situación se ha incrementado
la migración hacia territorio dominicano
desde Haití eso es algo palpable
y algo que
realmente nos preocupa como dominicanos
sobre todo por la cultura haitiana que
es una cultura muy diferente a la que
tenemos Los dominicanos Ellos tienen una
forma de vida que podíamos decir tiene
unos cincuenta años de atraso que hay
que reforzar la la hay que hay que
reforzar no la militarización la mano
dura
yo soy un creyente en la legalidad todo
el que esté en este territorio debe
estar sobre la base de un marco legal el
que está dentro de un marco ilegal debe
ser repatriado a su país de origen
entendemos que la mano de obra tiene
determinante de los nacionales haitianos
es muy importante en el sector
agropecuario construcción etcétera
etcétera Pero tiene que haber un marco
jurídico legal que regule pero existen
denuncias que entre los deportados hay
mujeres haitianas en estado de embarazo
la crisis haitiana obliga a las mujeres
a realizar cruces ilegales hacia
dominicana para poder dar a luz a sus
hijos el 30,5% de los partos registrados
en los hospitales públicos de República
Dominicana en 2021 eran de haitianas
según estadísticas publicadas por el
servicio nacional de salud para
noviembre del 2022 la cifra se duplicó
datos que confirman los médicos de los
hospitales cerca de la zona fronteriza
en el año 2022 se hicieron en este
centro 125 partos Y de lo cual el 95
fueron
a nacionales extranjeras de en su
mayoría de origen haitiano y el
dominicana residente en la zona como
médico es parte de nuestro día a día
como hospital representa una carga
porque en cuanto a la subvención del
centro no están contemplados los
extranjeros Entonces ellos consumen los
recursos de los pacientes locales la
atención se le da igualitariamente
humanizada igual que a todo el mundo
aquí sin importar Ni color ni raza en
Haití la violencia se desató en
septiembre del 2022 cuando el gobierno
decretó la suspensión de varios
subsidios a los combustibles lo que
provocó la convulsión social y también
más violencia de parte de las pandillas
que controlan Puerto Príncipe ahora con
la idea en Haití de una intervención
militar extranjera que cobra fuerza cada
día más el comercio entre ambas naciones
se desarrolla con una tensa calva desde
República Dominicana les acompañó Jorge
Hurtado en esta edición de enlace
[Música]